you know
[Music]
do
thanks
okay
i know you're only one person scott
hello everybody welcome to the table my
name is karen i'm so glad you're here
welcome to advent season
i
i for one cannot believe were already to
that point of the year
i feel like
it was just january and i was saying oh
certainly 2021 is going to be better
than 2020. and here we are knocking on
2022's door
so wherever you find yourself tonight
i'm glad that you're here with us
here in the sanctuary and welcome to
those of you that are tuning in online i
have a few announcements ways to either
help out with some of the things we're
working on in our community or ways to
get connected here at the table
and
excuse me
i have my notes because we have a lot
and i want to make sure to get all of
the information correct
okay first if you look over your
shoulder we have our salvation army
angel tree back there and you'll notice
we only have two tags left
two that's it
so two tags are up for grabs for all of
you to fight nicely over um but we have
oh
oh oh oh oh
we have i think we're gonna have one tag
left yay kelly thank you
we have one tag that's it one tag and
then all of the
kids that we signed up to give gifts to
will be taken care of so
this is for the salvation army angel
tree and
the tags will say who the tag that's
left will say who you're buying for and
what's on their wish list and graham can
you raise your hand graham is organizing
this so if you would like to
uh be the last person to grab the tag
back there see graham
also if you grabbed a tag last week and
you have your stuff together or need to
figure out how to get that to graham or
to the salvation army please see graham
at the end of the service sound good and
that way we will have kids that are
getting gifts this christmas which is an
amazing thing so thanks to all of you
for being a part of that
secondly
ah
the youth holiday hangout
for our teens yeah this is exciting our
youth meetup is starting up it's
launching
and they're having their first gathering
a week from tonight so it'll be sunday
evening right after the service
basically it's here there will be food
provided so you don't have to worry
about your hungry teen going hungry and
maggie and her team have some fun things
in store so if you are a teen
7th through 12th grade or you know a
team that might be interested
please please come you are welcome this
is an affirming and inclusive youth
group maggie and her team are super
excited to get this up and running and
we can't do it without teens so it's a
great place to come and check out again
it's next week right after the service
it's going to start around 6 45 after we
get stuff all
torn down and put away
and then lastly
last week we made the announcement about
a rough refugee mom in need of diapers
for her baby that's on the way
there's gonna be a baby shower so if you
brought diapers tonight just put them
over underneath the tree over there
if you would still like to donate you
can do that just come see me after the
service and i'll let you know how to do
that and we can bless this mom
uh who is giving birth in a brand new
brand new country i can't even imagine i
cannot even imagine so if you don't want
to if you don't have access to going to
the store and getting diapers but you
want to donate some money towards it
that's also an option so again you can
come see me if you have any questions
about that
all right so how about if we
take some time just to calm ourselves
to remember why we're here
whatever brought you here
[Music]
take a moment to think about why you
came tonight why are you here either
here
physically in the sanctuary or why
you're tuning in online
what is it for you
then take a deep breath in
and exhale
you are here
you did the hard work of showing up
[Music]
whatever it is you walk through the
doors with or you're tuning in online
with
know that you're not alone
you're among friends
one of the names of jesus is emmanuel
god with us
so my prayer for us tonight is wherever
we find ourselves that we would
experience the wonder
and the presence
and the peace of jesus
so god we come to you tonight
[Music]
we offer up
ourselves our hearts our minds
we surrender to you god
open our hearts
help us to experience your wonder
and your presence and your peace tonight
and god i also pray for those who
are hurting or suffering
feeling alone god
that you would fill them with your
spirit
and maybe may the table be a place of
community
where people are known just as they are
where they can be their authentic selves
and vulnerable
and find you god in the midst of it
so thank you god thank you for being
with us
and we thank you for the things you are
doing among us
in jesus name amen
[Music]
thanks karen well you guys why don't
y'all stand your feet with us i hope
everyone had a great thanksgiving we
just got in from new mexico late last
night and i'm so grateful to be back
together
with more friends and family here so i
hope that you feel like that i hope you
feel at home and like you're amongst
friends um and that's what our worship
is it's time for us to gather as a
community and lift up
songs that we believe are true about who
jesus is and who god is and how he wants
to interact with us um
so if you feel like that is true as
we're going through it just we invite
you to join in with us sing along or if
you would rather
sit and reflect or if you want to engage
your body and clap or
raise your hands um this is an open
space for you so just be at home here
and joe's gonna get us started
[Music]
where can we ride
where can we hide
is there a place that we can go
where you cannot find us
you're there when we fall
and when we rise
nothing is hidden from your face
you know every breath
we take
[Music]
love has found us your love has found us
we are yours forever
[Music]
nothing in all the universe
can take us from your love
you came to us
made us your own
[Music]
you have redeemed us from the fall
us
your love has found us with all around
holding us together
your love has found us your love has
found us
we are yours forever
your love
is all around us
holding us together
we will sing because your love has found
us even in the darkest nights we'll sing
because your love has set us up
your love has found eyes your love has
found us
we are yours forever
your love has found us this all around
us
holding us together
[Music]
we will is
because your love has found us even in
the darkest nights will sing because
you're the best
will sing because your love has found us
the darkest nights will sing because
you're the best
[Music]
are you hurting broken within
overwhelmed by the weight of your sin
jesus is calling
[Music]
have you come to the end of yourself
do your thirst for a drink from the well
jesus is calling
[Music]
oh come to
the altar
the father's arms are open wide
[Music]
forgiveness
was bought with
the precious blood of jesus christ
[Music]
leave behind your regrets and mistakes
come today there's no reason to wait
jesus is calling
[Music]
bring your sorrow and trade them for joy
from the ashes a new life
jesus
[Music]
the
father's arms are open
the wide
was brought with
the precious blood of jesus christ oh
come to
the altar
the
father's arms are open wide
mess
was brought with
the precious blood of jesus christ
[Music]
and isn't he wonderful
sing hallelujah
christ is a reason
[Music]
bow down
before him
[Music]
sing hallelujah
christ is
[Music]
isn't he wonderful
sing hallelujah
[Music]
christ is a reason
to bow down before
[Music]
sing hallelujah
christ is
[Music]
the
father's arms
[Music]
the precious blood of jesus christ
would you guys join us in our prayer of
the people and if you're online please
feel free to leave a comment and karen
will read it out so that you can be part
of our service as well
[Music]
jesus for the city of saxi texas and for
every city and community
and all those who live in him
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you for those who travel on
land sea or air
we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan for the injured and the
suffering
we pray to you for the poor and the
oppressed the unemployed and the
destitute for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them
we pray to you
and lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
so now we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
angelina
only 56 years old gone too soon
[Music]
the fath family
and the marble family
my grandmother
[Music]
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
and isn't he wonderful
i've seen hallelujah
christ is risen
bow down before
him
[Music]
christ is rising
christ is
[Music]
[Applause]
hallelujah
[Music]
is
bow down before
[Music]
sing hallelujah
christ is risen
o come to
the
altar
the father's
[Music]
the precious blood of jesus christ
with
[Music]
bury your cross as you wait for the
crown
[Music]
tell the world of the treasure he found
praise god
from whom
all
blessings flow
praise him all creatures
here below
[Music]
praise him
above ye
heavenly
hosts
praise father
[Music]
praise god from whom all
blessings
praise him all
creatures
hear
me
[Music]
oh
we sing
[Music]
ah
jesus thank you for this time together
[Music]
thank you for the space
to sing about who you are
and who we are inside of you god
people who are not lost but are found
people who can bring
all of ourselves all of our story
our pain our victory
our doubts
our questions
and find room here at your table
find space
to be who you created us to be
and to find love god
a love that goes beyond understanding
that doesn't give up
a love that is patient and kind
god we're grateful tonight
and as we finish out this week of
thanksgiving god it's with gratitude
[Music]
even for the hard moments
for the broken places in our lives god
we want to find you there we want to
meet you there
and believe that you are with us
that you are there on the mountains and
you are going to be there in our valleys
you are not far away
would we live like that
believing that there is a hope greater
than what we even know or see today god
a hope that goes beyond tomorrow
a love that surpasses all things
[Music]
thank you for who you are thank you for
this community and these people who love
us
through the midst of our stories god
would you be real and present and speak
to us tonight as brett speaks
would we have ears
to hear what's on your heart it's in
your name i pray amen
thank you guys so much for sharing with
us in worship and as you're getting
seated if you want to turn and say hello
to the people around you that would be
great that's going to get us started
with this message
well good evening
grace and peace it is so good to be with
all of you i do hope you had a good
thanksgiving
with people you love you know like mindy
my sister-in-law mentioned um we
kind of the whole family traveled out to
new mexico so i got some
time in the mountains
that's nice isn't it any fans of
mountains
man it's just i don't know what it is
it's just
the majesty of god and it's so still why
was that um
a christian camp out there glorietta but
of course it's thanksgiving so i mean it
was empty
and so it was just so quiet i would get
up early in the morning to run and it
was just
quiet
so good so so good so i feel i'm feeling
restored even though i had some long
drives you know monday friday long
drives but i'm feeling restored so i
hope i hope you're feeling that that too
even the midst of you know the cooking
and the preparation and the cleaning and
all that that you um had some some time
for restoration so uh it is a joy just
to be with you all and i wanna welcome
all of you but
especially those who are new thank you
for being here tonight um
and those joining us online we love you
lots you're not forgotten so um
we are in let's see we've kind of hit
the pause button on our uh series on
first peter we're working through that
book but um we can only make it through
chapter one before it's time for advent
so or pause button on peter jumping over
to advent i i like um
we like in certain times of the year
kind of joining on the church calendar
um because it's just a good reminder
that it's not just about us you know and
like well these are our interests or
these are things we're passionate about
or you know or our little community but
it's like we're joining in with the
broader
church in um
in certain times of year and so this is
one of those times that i think it's
really cool to be able to just join in
with what churches i mean man millions
of churches all over the world are um
kind of
entering into season of advent so
um
for a little background on those
unfamiliar advent i know that's a
strange you know word uh comes from the
latin adventus which means arrival um or
coming so it's really a um kind of a
season of preparation as we approach
christmas so it's not the same as kind
of the christmas season
you can think of advent is to christmas
as lent is to easter
all right if you're familiar with those
two most people know easter maybe not
everyone's familiar with lint but
easter's like resurrection and like
woohoo you know joy
and
lent is the season of preparation for
that right so it's the season of the
cross
and suffering and um
and kind of it's preparation right and
there's something about that i think
about taking some time to reflect and
prepare and kind of sit with um you know
because advent really it's it's kind of
it's a season of hope but it's like a
hope to come in the future you know it's
that moment where you like sit with not
having all the answers and just praying
that god shows up you know that's advent
like it's not christmas it's not his
here you know but it's it's i trust i
trust that god's gonna meet me you know
so it's it's that season of preparation
and there's something i think really
beautiful and helpful about that um
because if you even think of just good
stories it may be really odd for a story
to just cut to like the best part you
know like if you're a movie like movies
and books and novels like they have a
certain flow right we know the story
like you kind of have to go to hell
before you go to heaven you know and if
that doesn't happen you just jump
straight to like huh and he won you know
or she was a victor it's sort of like oh
okay i guess uh story over uh so that's
that's kind of where we're not jumping
right into christmas but it's a it's a
season of preparation for that
so uh the title of my message tonight oh
i should mention our series
is already up there but it's a wonder
making room for advent that's the the
series title and then the the message
tonight is titled the visitation the
visitation our primary text is going to
be luke chapter 21
verses 25 through 36 you can
follow along in your bibles or on the
screen
verse 25 this is jesus speaking there
will be signs in the sun the moon and
the stars
on the earth nation will be in anguish
and perplexity at the roaring and
tossing of the sea people will faint
from terror apprehensive of what is
coming on the world for the heavenly
bodies will be shaken
at that time they will see the son of
man coming in a cloud with power and
great glory when these things begin to
take place stand up lift up your heads
because your redemption is drawing near
and he told them this parable look at
the fig tree and all the trees when they
sprout leaves you can see for yourselves
and you know that summer is near even so
when you see these things happening you
know that the kingdom of god is near
truly i tell you this generation will
certainly not pass away until all these
things have happened heaven and earth
will pass away but my words they will
never pass away be careful
or your hearts will be weighed down with
carousing and drunkenness and the
anxieties of life and that day will
close on you suddenly like a trap
for it will come on all those who live
on the face of the whole earth be always
on the watch and pray that you may be
able to escape all that is about to
happen and that you may be able to stand
before the son of man
can you tell that's not a christmas
can you hear it's probably picking up on
like oh where's the baby in the manger
you know
um that's advent now um this is i think
this is a fascinating passage um maybe
many of you are already wondering where
is he gonna go with this um so i think
the way i probably this hits different
people in different ways maybe some of
you are completely mystified like i have
no idea what he just read you know and
then others um if you've been if you're
kind of been in the church for a while
you're familiar with christian you know
theology and tradition and such um
probably what was kind of coming to mind
was something like the the what's known
as the second coming or arrival of jesus
um
and and probably it's where that's
coming from is the language right it's
very it's just it's a very it's what um
scholars call apocalyptic language
meaning um it is dramatic and cosmic
right you can think of there's even
similar passages like the book of
matthew where it's like it's still
talking about the heavens and such the
sun um and the moon will be darkened the
stars will fall from the sky i mean it's
like you know in that day so it's all
very kind of dramatic and
where that tends to take our minds is to
something like the you know the second
uh arrival of uh jesus um
and uh and i think that makes a certain
amount of sense because you know the
church has kind of confessed like in
even the creed um you know that the
christ you was the resurrected and
ascended one will come again to judge
the living and the dead so there is in
scripture this kind of idea of the the
second arrival of christ
um
however what i want to contend tonight
is that actually a lot of the passages
that we read
like this one or here and we're like
okay wow
i think that's that whole end of the
world
judgment day
jesus coming again thing that a lot of
the passages that we read and we hear
and interpret in that way actually um
are not talking about that
advent moment that arrival of jesus
i think we kind of mis-misread
misinterpret at times now it's not to
say every passage in the new testament
is you know not talking about that i do
think there are some i mean first
corinthians 15 kind of touches on this i
think the very end of the book of
revelation kind of touches on that
though a lot of people read the whole
book as like oh it's all about the end
of the world you know um
when actually i think what jesus is
doing is using that apocalyptic language
which was very popular in his time this
was like a genre of literature um that
people would use this cosmic language
big language but he was actually talking
about very um today
or um
events happening like in the earth
kind of thing right it's what's known as
like imminent language like soon to
happen kind of things
not you know heaven or your soul is in
danger so turn to me or else in the day
of the lord you shall be judged like
that's that where we kind of take way to
the future um i think that's where we
get a little bit off so
okay so why on earth do i think a text
that seems to be talking about the end
of all things
actually is not talking about the end
of all things i'm getting
little commands to switch
boom all mics
uh so okay so i wanna the the primary
reason i think that
um is really about context so i wanna do
tonight the first part of the message
will be in the bible a lot hang with me
uh because there's i think we'll kind of
have some payoff towards the end but i
want to give you some context from the
chapters before this so this is one
reason i think
this apocalyptic big old language is
actually talking about very practical
political economic social thing is going
on in jesus day so we're going to start
by looking at um or i'll talk i'll walk
you through luke chapter 19. so in luke
jesus and the disciples
they are approaching jerusalem
and jesus sees the city in the distance
and he starts crying
and he starts crying the bible literally
says jesus starts weeping
and he he says that the the reason it's
because he knows
what is to come
what is to happen
uh now our minds might immediately drift
to like the cross you know which is true
that was a thing to to come
but
that's not actually what he was crying
about
and instead um he goes on to explain
that the reason he's crying
is because he he realizes that he's been
doing his ministry now for like three
years
and he knows that while a certain small
percentage of people have kind of
embraced him in his message of the
nearness of the kingdom of god
by and large
people have not
especially when he started talking about
the cross
you know and enemy love and
all of a sudden it was like oh this
isn't the deliverer we were hoping for
we wanted someone to slaughter the
romans you don't seem interested in
slaughtering the romans you know so he
knows that his kind of message of
you know a gracious god um forgiving 70
times seven
um
the kind of servant
you know that way of service like he
just knows that his his message that the
kingdom of god is here and happening in
his life and ministry which is actually
about laying down your life
right to find it
being willing to suffer hardship and
conflict and um even
pain
like that that his message he just knows
like people haven't just everyone's not
embraced it right and so what he says is
he starts crying
now we might again our mind drifts to
like oh it's in because of that their
souls are in danger and if they don't
repent and they're going to go to the
bad place and this is where we can have
this whole theology worked out but like
we have to be really careful of kind of
placing that on jesus all of our
elaborate theology when actually no he
wasn't crying about that
he was
he was crying because he knew
that a certain destruction was going to
come on the city you're like the
spiritual city no not like the spiritual
right
like the actual city of jerusalem that's
why he was crying
in fact he says
what's going to happen
is
because
because the people have not used the
language of they have not recognized the
time of their visitation
that's what he says they haven't
recognized the time of their visitation
right emmanuel god with us they have not
realized who is in their midst
and he says they have not learned the
things that make for peace
and because of this
not just in some otherworldly spiritual
sense or at the end of the world sense
no no in a very literal sense
he says
i think he used language of gentile so
he doesn't say romans but everyone knows
who he's talking about the romans have
conquered them many times you know
the romans are gonna they're gonna build
a siege bank embankment against your
walls they're gonna go throughout the
city they're gonna dash people to the
ground and they're gonna tear the temple
down stone by stone
now you have to understand like the
temple for jewish people like this it
was the center literally of the world
it was the center of their whole life
and identity
it was everything
and he says it's going to be torn down
stone by stone
um so that's luke 19.
then you fast forward chapter 20 goes
some different directions then luke 21
he circles back to some very it's i mean
it's all the same it's like a whole lot
more of the same
this time though jesus and the disciples
now they're not outside jerusalem
they're actually in the city in fact
they're in the temple
and one of the disciples comments upon
the beautiful stonework
and
jesus says
i tell you a day is coming when not one
stone will be left upon another
and the disciple i mean
they just have this visceral bodily
reaction like
what i mean they just can't believe it
like that's impossible like this is
god's place this is where literally the
presence of the living god is right here
there is no way this place gets
conquered there's no way that this house
this house of god gets torn down stone
by snow it's just it's not possible in
fact you could even point in the old
testament to certain scriptures that
would seem to indicate just that like no
no god is here god is on our side there
is no way that's going to happen
and he's like i'm telling you
i'm telling you you haven't recognized
the time of your visitation
like it's coming
and then he he says this this is verse
10 well they basically they ask well how
will we know
how will we know when this will take
place he responds verse 10 of luke 21
then he said to them nation will rise
against nation kingdom against kingdom
there will be great earthquakes and
famines and pestilences and various
places and fearful events and great
signs from heaven can you hear the
apocalyptic thing happening right
they're looking for signs and all of a
sudden it's like cosmic big big stuff
but then it gets actually much more kind
of concrete and practical
um verse 20. so skipping down nine
verses and he says this like well how
will you know what are the signs verse
20 is a pretty good sign when you see
jerusalem being surrounded by armies you
will know that its desolation is near
pretty straightforward right like
how will we know the sign of you know
not the end of all things but this this
coming disaster how do we know well
you'll you know be a pretty good clue
when it's like you're sieged and they're
surrounded by an army and you're trapped
in the walls
that would uh yep that'll do it you know
that'll be your moment um he goes on
though with this like almost really um
scary description verse 21 then let
those
who are in judea which is like the
region around there around jerusalem
flee the mountains let those in the city
get out let those in the country not
enter the city for this is the time of
punishment and fulfillment of all that
has been written how dreadful it will be
in those days for pregnant women and
nursing mothers you can imagine if you
have to flee a city
um as basically a refugee like this
would be a bad time to be pregnant or
nursing
there will be great distress in the land
wrath against this people they will fall
by the sword they'll be taken as
prisoners to all the nations jerusalem
will be trampled on by the gentiles
in the times
of the until the times the gentiles are
fulfilled that's verse 24 which then
leads right into verse 25 which is the
passage we begin with and then
the you know there will be signs and the
sun and the moon and the stars and it
goes right into the passage we we opened
with
um okay
so
so again what i want you to kind of
track is can you see how jesus is using
this very big language that again kind
of strikes us as into the world kind of
stuff but he's not describing
necessarily the end of the world
at least in this passage he's using that
big apocalyptic language to talk about
something much more practical and
concrete very this world practical type
events now um perhaps you're not
convinced well i think um
verse 32 also
kind of makes it pretty clear did you
catch the little line in verse 32 in our
original reading where he says this and
truly i tell you what this generation
will not or certainly will not pass away
until all of these things have happened
right so
again when our minds drift to it's the
end of the world you know well if so
then jesus was deluded
because i think we can all agree the end
of the world has not
happened
and yet he said that generation would
pass away before all of these things
take place right so i think it's it's
pretty clear that he's not talking about
the end of the world
and by the way there are biblical
scholars who actually think jesus um
it was deluded like he really thought oh
my return shall happen before this
generation passes away and all these
terrible things will have the end of the
world and yet he like you know it didn't
happen it didn't he was kind of a huxter
or something um now
i um i
don't think
um i don't think jesus was deluded
i think our readings of this
these kinds of verses have often times
been somewhat um deluded
and um
we've you know we've read it as
primarily prediction about the end of
the world when actually he's talking
about the destruction of jerusalem
and of course the natural question is
well he said that would happen before
this generation passes away
did it
um and the answer to that is yes
in the year 80 70. so about 40 years
after
jesus made this prediction
that's exactly what happened the romans
show up
surround the city build the siege ramps
and it was
apocalyptic
it was hell on
earth there's actually a fascinating
there's a man
a jewish historian named flavius
or how do you say his name yeah flavius
josephus
and he's not in the bible he's not a
biblical writer but he's someone who
wrote about that time so he wrote a
jewish history at that time here's a
quote about that siege of the romans in
the city of jerusalem
throughout the city people were dying of
hunger in large numbers
they were enduring unspeakable
sufferings in every house the merest
hint of food sparked violence
close relatives fell to blows snatching
from one another the pitiful supports of
life
no respect was paid even to the dying
the ruffians those were the anti-roman
zealots searched them in case they were
concealing food somewhere in their
clothes or just pretending to be near
death
gaping with hunger like mad dogs lawless
gangs went staggering and reeling to the
streets battering upon the doors like
drunkards and so bewildered they broke
in the same house two or three times in
an hour need drove the starving to gnaw
at anything
refuse which even animals could reject
or would reject was collected and turned
into food in the end they were eating
belts and shoes and the leather stripped
off their shields
it was a
horrible
siege of the city of jerusalem
so i don't think jesus was deluded
i think jesus was all too
right when he came to jerusalem and he
starts crying
that's why it was he wasn't crying about
the end of the world
he was crying about the end of their
world
by the end of the life as they knew it
that's what moved him so much
okay
that's a lot of bible
so what on earth does this have to say
to us
in our day in our time thank you for
your patience
um
because it is it's a good question i
mean what what is jesus speaking about
you know this impending roman conquest
of jerusalem
how does this translate into the 21st
you know century
um i think here's here's our big idea
for tonight um it's easier than we think
to miss the time of our visitation
i think that's the take home it's easier
than we think to miss the time of our
visitation like the people back then
they didn't realize what was happening
like god was showing up for them
and offering them a way out
and they completely missed it
and it might be easy to look back with a
certain judgment like well we wouldn't
miss it
i'm not so sure
it's easier than we think to miss the
time of our visitation
there's a christian writer richard beck
he um talks about the
three well we tend to think of the two
arrivals of jesus you know but he says
actually if you think about it there's
kind of three
arrivals
of christ in the world
he said the first is of course the
incarnation this is christmas right
this the third
is at the end of all things as the creed
says when he comes again to judge the
living and the dead
but the second
is actually happening
all of the time
because through the holy spirit
christ is present to us
and he is always
um visiting
and showing up in your life and in my
life
and he is trying to teach us the things
that make for peace
he is trying to show us the way forward
and out
he's kind of he's really trying to say
like don't miss the time of your
visitation like i am here i am present i
mean this is the language of the
psalmist right who said like where can i
go god where can i flee from your
presence
right if i go up to the heavens you're
there if i go down to the depths of hell
you're there if i go north or south or
east or west before behind me like
you're there you're there and this is
like for us as christians like
the god we've come to know in jesus
where on earth could we go where god is
not
nowhere like christ is always present
he is always showing up
speaking to us and inviting us to more
it's showing us the way forward showing
us the way out teaching us the things
that make for peace
i have this um funny moment with people
um if you're
a leader here and i have like a
recurring call or meeting with you i've
probably asked you this question
and it's um
it's probably i think it's one of the
most important questions that i ask
people but i can also tell
people find it a little bit annoying and
confusing and this is the question um i
say so
um
what
what is christ teaching you
and then people look at me
with a little bit of puzzlement on their
face you know it's like what
what do you mean
what a strange question i think they
eventually get used to it and they kind
of know you know what i'm getting at
but uh it is a strange i admit it's a
strange question
um
and yet i i think in light of this
message like what i'm really asking
is basically
do you recognize
the time of your visitation
the second coming
right do you recognize how god is
showing up in your life
like what is he saying to you
what is he speaking what
where are you being stretched
where are you growing
where is god challenging you where is he
calling you to more
what's the thing that he's like just
pressing on
and you're like oh
i don't want to go there
like of anywhere i'll go anywhere god
we'll talk about anything deal with any
issue ask any question just not that one
and yet that's always right like this is
exactly where god goes
and and we know it's like painful and
yet it's we know it's good
it's good what's
what's that about like that's it's a key
key question are are we
recognizing the time of our visitation
because christ is present
he's speaking he's leading
are we like are we tuning in to it
and you know thinking about luke 19 luke
21 i was thinking about the language of
you know being saved because that's
really i think these are salvation
passages when jesus is crying he's like
i'm trying to save you again when as
christians we hear that language and we
jump right to like the soul save my soul
you know which is true like god does but
he needs to save all of us right like
and i mean not all people i mean like my
whole being body soul spirit mind
emotions like we need to be saved that's
the message of luke 19 luke 21 like we
need to be saved but not just in some
spiritually sense right but in like very
practical
i guess think again of those first
century that audience like what did they
need to be saved from they need to be
saved from their violence
saved from their hatred they had such
venom
against their oppressors that they tried
they tried an insane thing
they tried to throw off rome with
violence like it was the crime it was
crazy and jesus knew it was insane like
what are you doing
they need to be saved from their
violence saved from their hatred and
their hostility
and resentment
saved from their crazy images of god
that are like not
the god
revealed in jesus
can you be saved from their anger
they need to be safe from themselves
and are we really so different
nope
we need to be safe don't we
we need to be saved
we too
need to learn the things that make for
peace that's the message don't miss the
time of your visitation
he's present
he's speaking
don't miss it
so
i'll go first
here's what jesus is
here's what he's teaching me
and if you've listened to my messages
you'd say oh brett he's been teaching
you that for years i know but i'm just
still working on it
um
jesus is teaching me to be vulnerable
and real
and um
i mostly hate it
i mostly miss the time of my visitation
you know it's hard like i think probably
the only thing worse than being really
vulnerable and honest and really like
putting your heart out there is
not
putting your heart out there and like
being vulnerable and real because then
you know you live with walls and you
keep people at like arm's length and you
know it's like it's nice in the short
run but
it's not a long-term strategy you know
so that's what i'm working on trying to
be
vulnerable real i had a conversation
with my wife we were at olive garden
like 10 days ago
and i'm sitting there in all gardening
i'm opening up i'm sharing things like
just fears
fears um
my fear of failure
my fear of um
abandonment
i have so many people that love me i
don't know why i'm so afraid
i am
and i'm sharing this and i start to you
know i'm talking with maggie and my wife
at olive garden and i start to like i'm
kind of feeling it you know and like the
tears kind of start coming down my face
and our waitress walks up she's like hey
are you guys okay i'm like we're fine
yeah everything's great you know i'm
like i don't know what she's thinking
like she breaking up with you you know
what what's going on
but you know what was happening well at
least in that moment i wasn't missing
the time of my visitation you know
at least in that moment
and that's that's what i said that's me
that's what i need to be saved from
so how about
you about you
yeah
patience
brian started it
anyone else
um appreciation
yeah
mmm forgiveness
oh
those are deep waters
safety
it's
beautiful
yeah let's let's not miss the time of
our visitation
christ is present
he's speaking he's faithful
through the spirit he's leading us
let's keep trusting so this this advent
um
let's learn the things that make for
peace
peace in our own hearts and minds peace
our relationships our friendships
marriages
families
communities
world
let's learn the things that make for
peace
you close your eyes by your heads let me
close with a prayer
lord jesus how
how blind we can be
failing to see what you're trying to
teach us
and we just
take so much of the bible and just throw
it a thousand years into the future
and we miss how remarkable and beautiful
and practical
and relevant your words are for our life
here and now
god help us to repent
help us to be saved
reconcile heal us
and then send us out as agents of
reconciliation and healing people who
have learned the things that make for
peace and can
put it out there in the world
your people
in the name
of the father
and the son
and the holy spirit
amen
[Music]
thank you brett
woo
all right
but what i want us to kind of hang on to
i was thinking about in light of what
brett just
was sharing with us um
how this
song is
uh so fitting almost like a prayer
um in our practical life right now um
today and tomorrow
and and inviting god into the space and
saying i i'm not going to miss i don't
want to miss it i want to see where
you're at in my life i want to find you
in all of these moments i want to
experience what you're trying to teach
me
so if you guys could join us in this and
let's just make it kind of a prayer
almost a journal entry of sorts to god
for this week
um
and maybe take it with you into your
week maybe begin each day reading
through these lyrics and um we could
even post them on our site and if you
follow the table it would be an easy
place to find them so i'll try to make
them accessible but i just feel like
it's a very fitting and timely way for
us to wrap up this message and also to
begin our advent season to begin our
days and our week saying
i want to find you i want to see you
where are you god
so um
if you guys want to stand with us and
let's sing this together as kind of a
prayer as we close out tonight
god i look to you
i won't be overwhelmed
[Music]
give me vision
to see things like you do
god i look to you
you're where my help comes from
[Music]
give me wisdom
you know just what to do
[Music]
god i look to you
i won't be overwhelmed
give me vision
to see things
[Music]
you know just what to
lord my strength
[Music]
and i will love you
lord my
rock
forever all my days i will love you guys
god i look to you
i won't be overwhelmed
[Music]
give me visions
get me wisdom
[Music]
you know just what to do
and i will love you
lord my strength
[Music]
my
rock forever all my days
[Music]
hallelujah
god reigns
[Music]
our
god reigns
forever all my days
[Music]
thank you guys that was beautiful
thank you so much for being here tonight
i hope that
every part of this service
helped you to experience the love and
the peace and the grace of christ
just a few things before we go
don't forget the angel tree graham will
be back there if you have questions or
want to get that last tag
also if you had questions about the
diapers let me know i'll be up here
after service also as you came in
tonight you might have seen some setup
happening for an event out there that's
pleasant valley who we rent this space
from they're having an event tonight
called light up the corner it's gonna
start at 6 30 so perfect timing
very family-friendly event they're going
to have hot cider hot chocolate pictures
with santa you can make advent wreaths
gonna sing christmas carols and then
around 7 15 they do the ceremonial
lighting up of the tree
so they wanted us to know that we're
more than welcome to join them they're
like our extended family so please feel
free and welcome to be a part of that if
you wish
also if you're visiting with us tonight
we have cards that are out this back
door and to your right on the little
table if you could fill that out with
your name and contact information just
put it in that box
and we'll get in contact with you this
week
before we go
i'd like to send you all out with this
benediction so if you are able please
stand up
and these are words that i believe to be
true
for every single one of you here and
online so if you'd like to receive them
feel free to hold out your hands
[Music]
to receive this truth
you are a child of god
you
are a child of god
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go
filled with god's holy spirit and the
desire to extend these gifts of
unconditional love and grace to
everybody you come in contact with
have a great week be blessed and we hope
to see you back here next sunday good
night
[Music]
whoa that's exciting
with my souls
[Music]
with my soul
it is
[Music]